ça nous coûtait 6800 dollars l'année
dernière et on a une hausse qui monte ne
1200 dollars ça veut dire une
alimentation d'environ 40 points c'est
roger guillon administre cette résidence
pour aînés autonomes depuis des années
il n'est pas seul à voir les coûts
d'assurance grimper cette situation est
répandue et dénoncer on a vu même des
résidences privées pour aînés près par
de la paille recevoir une hausse de 9 5%
ou lahrech pour la partie responsabilité
des administrateurs la responsabilité en
cas de poursuite c'est ce que craindrait
les assureurs
une situation exacerbée par la crise de
l'aco vide
la ministre responsable des aînés
prévoit aider les résidences de 100
unités et moins une heure paiera d'une
vingtaine d'unités qui devait payer en
2010 9 1 4000 dollars d'assurance en
2021 2022 13 dollars d'assurances à une
augmentation de 9000 $ donc c'est du 225
% d'augmentation
on les dit l'augmentation n'est ni le
gouvernement va défrayer une 600 dollars
les résidences pour obtenir jusqu'à
25000 200 dollars mais le programme est
temporaire et il faut une solution
permanente dit on sur le terrain du
chapiteau un plaster celle bobobo
l'instinct la ministre explique que son
gouvernement planche sur des solutions à
plus long terme peut-être l'arrivée avec
un programme plus substantielles ou
d'arrivée aussi à travailler avec des
compagnies d'assurance
mais je veux pas m'avancer trop mais je
peux vous dire que le ministère des
finances le ministre de la santé et des
services sociaux travaillent dans ce
sens il faut s'y attaquer dès maintenant
nous on est disposé à travailler avec le
gouvernement mais on est d'avis qu'il
faut pas lâcher
les assureurs allez je pense comme ça
légiférer pour contrôler les assureurs
c'est ce que souhaite le regroupement
des résidences pour aînés
ainsi toutes les résidences seraient
protégés et à long terme ici
un bus hier radio-canada saint-isidore